[Musique]
aujourd'hui un quart des décès dans le
monde sont dus à une dégradation de
l'environnement pollution de l'air
pollution des eaux des produits toxiques
en france on a un système qui est
extrêmement fondée sur le soin donc les
individus ton malade et puis ensuite on
les soigne et très peu fondées sur la
prévention pour éviter que les personnes
sont malades on a en france la moitié
des individus qui arrivent à 60 ans en
n'étant pas en bonne santé l'espérance
de vie est dans la moyenne européenne
mais l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
est faible en français il ya un concept
qui existe le concept de santé unique
pour agir à la fois sur la santé des
hommes et des femmes et à la santé de la
planète de l'environnement et de la
biodiversité tout est lié donc l'idée
c'est de pouvoir je pense apporter une
réponse globale pour améliorer
l'environnement global des individus
pour préserver le capital santé
la première question qu'on se posait
c'était identifier ces nouveaux risques
que font peser sur nous le le
réchauffement climatique voilà quels
sont ils donc on voit qu'il ya plus de
pollution chimique plus de pollution
hormonal et c'est la deuxième question
c'était la question du financement la
troisième question
c'est la question du modèle économique
on sait qu'on va avoir besoin de faire
vider transition économique il ya des
secteurs d'activités qui vont
disparaître d'autres qui vont naître
comment on peut accompagner les salariés
dans cette transition et l'a3 la
quatrième question pardon qu'on se pose
c'est l'ouverture de nouveaux droits
comme la question d'insécurité sociale
alimentaire conçoit cette mission comme
étant plutôt une mission de prospective
du réflexion parce qu'après il est bon
de poser un diagnostic sur les nouveaux
risques
catastrophes naturelles et après c'est
voir comment on y répond et quelles
solutions en termes de financement peut
apporter pour gérer et apporter une
meilleure santé à nos compatriotes
[Musique]